[Musique]
qu'à l'occasion de la journée
internationale du droit des femmes j'ai
souhaité organiser un moment une
rencontre entre des femmes et des jeunes
lycéennes ou étudiantes sur le thème des
femmes et de l'audace qui est je crois
nécessaire utile à la construction des
femmes j'ai voulu donner à voir des
modèles inspirants donc il y avait
quatre audacieuse une femme chef de
cuisine une navigatrice
une femme chef d'entreprise et une
responsable politique dont nous avons
rencontré des jeunes filles d'une
vingtaine d'années juste leur dire que
tout est possible tout est dans la tête
qu'il faut apprendre à oser apprendre à
dépasser ses limites que le seul risque
qu'on a c'est l'échec est alors et vous
vous dis ça je vais oser est ok c'est
quoi ces valeurs
j'ai beaucoup aimé la phrase qui a dit
la chef d'entreprise quand elle a dit
que ben en fait malgré les échecs en
fait qu'il fallait toujours continuer en
fait à faire ce qu'on aimait et j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment fort et du cou en
fait j'ai souvent peur parfois de faire
des choses parce que je me dis que je
vais pas forcément réussir et du coup ça
ça va vraiment me servir je pense dans
l'aide tous les jours je tiens je
commence vraiment passionné de cuisine
fille et le dlc arrive à ce moment là
j'étais vraiment passionné pour ce
métier là je voulais vraiment y arriver
je me dis qu'une femme n'est pas plus
faible qu'un homme donc pas quel courage
à deux mains et puis vas-y en fait voilà
pour nous note récompenser d'avoir une
tête de chien on a travaillé durant de
l'énervement galère avoir une étoile
c'est déjà beaucoup de travail c'est un
objectif à atteindre pour le
restaurateur mais de l'avoir en huit
mois si c'est juste lisible et une fois
qu'on s'est trouvée c'est un branchement
ça quand même
une fois qu'on a pris confiance en nous
une fois qu'on a vraiment un rêve tout
ce qui est audace courage tout ça ça
vient ça vient tout seul puis surtout
s'affranchir des pressions sociales
c'est la liberté ultime face de moi je
suis en première année des tms c'est un
diplôme technique je me mettais du
spectacle en construction bois et
machinerie dont ceux qui vont faire les
changements de décors et tout ça c'est
un milieu essentiellement masculin quand
même on va pas se mentir la place de la
femme ou encore un peu compliqué j'ai un
rêve avec avec savait que le des tms et
j'aimerais bien être à leur place était
un jour et leur dire que ben j'ai osé
j'ai fait ce que je voulais faire quoi
il faut oser il faut croire en ses rêves
aussi l'audace et aussi c'est aussi
arrivé à s'affranchir de deir el du
chemin que tout tracé quelques fois
votre famille votre au milieu social 100
blessés
une envie autres par eve une fantaisie
une envie de différence laissez-lui
libre court à cette envie là comme ça il
ya la question de la légitimité sûr que
les femmes sont la leçon responsabilité
mais elles ne se sentent pas toujours
assez légitime
elles sont traversées par le doute elle
se pose des tas de questions cette
petite phrase qui trotte dans la tête de
trop de femmes
est ce que je peux le faire et bien
c'est cela que j'avais envie de
combattre par cette réunion que j'ai
organisé sur les femmes et l'audace ne
vous laissez jamais en doute vous foncez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]